all right we've got another patented
Dave Rubin reaction video for you today
I have just heard I will be watching six
videos of Andrew Tate uh Andrew Tate of
course who I think right now is under
house arrest in Romania if I'm not
mistaken but really known as an MMA guy
and sort of uh uh kind of if you're a
dude get your sh together kind of guy
and go get it sort of like a younger
sort of muscle ear Jordan Peterson type
I'm gonna watch six videos of him I have
not seen any of these videos and I'm
going to react on the internet to these
videos in real time video one
don't believe
don't message me about the question
because I don't believe in it you're
asleep in your bed in the middle of the
night and you hear a noise and you
believe in ghosts now you're afraid but
if you don't believe in ghosts ah it's
the win then you go back to school you
give the ghosts Power by believing in
them your house is only haunted if you
believe in ghosts belief is a powerful
thing hard to stand in front of you and
I want to tell you but I could punch you
as hard as I can in your sternum and I
could fracture it and send a splinter
into your heart would you allow me to
try
you wouldn't because you know I believe
I can I believe I can hurt any man on
the planet and that's why people are
afraid of you and you believe depression
is a crippling disease and that's why
you're afraid of
wow there's a lot there I mean well
first off uh if you hear a noise in your
bed at night it isn't automatically a
ghost or nobody it might be a man with a
knife like waiting for you to go to the
bathroom so uh I don't know if I can
fully get on board that but I like the
sort of believe to achieve I can hurt
any man around there so he's trying
something what is that tattoo what is
that tattoo of is that a bear or a wolf
or a it's a cobra he's got oh cause he's
Cobra Tate right got it okay very good
uh but uh I don't know that I'm fully on
board that because I think there's
something between believing in ghosts
and having healthy skepticism when you
hear some noise in your house
clip number two
imagine one day you're sitting in Paris
and having a coffee and terrorists roll
through their caves the person next to
you as their brains blowing you're gonna
stand there and be like
waiting to die like a I'm
gonna be like bang I've seen that before
okay boom boom duck and dive in take one
terrorist out next get the AK go Rambo
take out all the Pakistan why would he
have an AK while he was just having a
cup of coffee in the middle of Paris
he's still the other guys here
um well good for him I mean I think he
thinks he's living in Grand Theft Auto
or something like I wouldn't just sit
there if I was just sitting there like
no offense Brock if I was sitting there
in Paris with you and somebody blew your
brains out I don't think I would just
sit there I don't think I would grab a
gun and start shooting everybody if I
had a gun I guess I would shoot somebody
I'm pretty sure I would just calmly
step aside well you know is there a
bathroom
rip number three I don't think the world
has ever been equal that the modern
society we live in has been built by men
let's cut the crap all the roads you see
all the buildings you see everything
around you men built all of it when
women come along and say oh we're just
as important you are just as important
but you do had a completely different
role you fulfilled a different role in
society and I think now if you look at
the roles of society I believe men are
still doing their job but I don't know
if women are doing their job men are
still out here building the modern world
but when they come home now the girl's
like oh why should I cook for you
well he had me on the first like 80
percent of that and then at the end it's
like dude you just got to find a better
chick right like there were plenty of
women that want to cook for their guy
and keep the house in order and maybe
they're working during the day or
raising kids or anything else but the
the general concept of what we talk
about a lot on the show the idea that
men built a lot of these things meant
built cities and were underground with
cockroaches on them inhaling God knows
what and in coal mines and everything
else like there's not a lot of women
doing those things men like things women
like people that's real uh but you can
find a woman you got to find a woman who
can do both I believe that's what they
say
so get out there and find her
and search up if you were to look up the
highest IQs in the world the first 10
first 20 look them up are they men or
women I haven't done this look it up I
did highest IQ in the world literally
what comes up Marilyn Von Savant as one
of the world's highest IQs she is known
as the smartest person in the world cool
then then all right cool then I'm
totally wrong I never even said all I
told you is that the most stupid people
in the world were men the most
intelligent people in the world were men
I read a study on it four or five years
ago and I thought you know what I know
some stupid men I don't know women that
dumb I agree with that and I know some
really smart men I don't know women that
smart I agree I think you're very smart
but for everything you say there
couldn't be argument that an intelligent
woman wants nothing to do with you
because you think they're stupid but
stupid guys are like this guy's gonna
make me a ton of money so you run into a
lot of stupid guys the intelligent women
are going their own way well that would
be a large generalization Dave that's
what we're doing there's been a lot of
those isn't that what he does that's
that's his thing large generalizations
look I know some stupid people and I
know some bright people it really
doesn't necessarily early cross the the
gender Spectrum on that like I mean if I
was just to look at my I guess the guest
list of my show the most sort of
enlightened really smart people tend to
be male I mean I wonder if I broke down
the guest list of all the shows I've
ever done all the interviews I've ever
done of philosophers and religious
leaders and politicians and everything
like they're usually men great deep
thinkers etc etc but that's not to say
women aren't men and women are just
wired differently women care about
different things as I said in the
previous ones so I think that was kind
of like he might be ballparking it but
yeah it's a big it's a big
generalization there all right what else
we got and when you're 52 and you're
past it with no grandchildren in a house
by yourself and all your friends have
grandchildren this beautiful life and
you're sitting there by yourself do you
think the fact that you can afford a few
extra Gucci bags is going to genuinely
make you feel happy I was at my
grandmother's 93rd birthday I looked
there my grandmother had nine children
because there was my father and eight
more they all had a bunch of kids I
stood there and I looked at my 93 year
old grandmother and there was a room a
whole room full with maybe 70 people
that came from that one woman
isn't that remarkable nobody cared about
her career nobody asked what job she did
nobody asked me time she went to the
club nobody asked if she had time to go
to festivals no you had 70 sentient
beings including myself full of life
from one woman who dedicated herself to
being a mother and a good wife that is
beautiful
wow that's pretty good I mean that's
hitting like the good stuff about being
a woman and you know some of the other
stuff he was saying about them being
smart or whatever like there's also
various types of knowledge right and and
being the matriarch of a family it's one
of those things but that was reminding
of uh as I was watching it was when my
grandma my dad's mom was uh in her last
few hours at the hospital we knew you
know we had taken her off the machines
and everything after a couple days of
trying a few things towards the end and
she was in her late 80s and over the
course of the day you know when they
take you off the when they pull the tube
basically you know you could die like
that sometimes people asked I think
people can last a couple days off
everything so we had no idea uh this was
in New Jersey most of my family lived in
the New York City New York Jersey area
so throughout the day all the grandkids
the aunts the uncles all her children
everybody was coming some people my
cousin was flying in from Utah everyone
got there starting at like 8 A.M I was
there at about 9 A.M coming for New York
City but we all got there throughout the
day we all sat with her and held her
hand and told stories and we were crying
and laughing and fighting and all of the
stuff and then finally my last cousin
flying in from across the country he got
there at about seven o'clock P.M we all
sat there did our thing it was a
beautiful day representing her and then
at about 8 PM uh we just heard the the
sound there's just the beep the beep you
hear just this long beep and that that
meant it was over and it was a beautiful
ending so I think that is a life well uh
worth living and I think there's
something to that you know he said 53
years old and if you don't have any kids
and you got the Gucci bag and the all
the stuff it's like
I mean I can say it as a new parent I
have a lot of stuff I have the stuff
that I want I really do but having those
kids and that hopefully they all have
kids and you know I'll be grandpops one
day and all that stuff like you do start
realizing that there's some more
important stuff out there than just the
stuff itself how is that for deep what
else you got
breathe air you don't need a vape
I've never seen anyone with a vape yeah
so we go wait oh let me just go my
vape's done charging yeah
load it up
I mean I smoke cigars but I know what
the I'm doing
give me a big fat cigar I'm risking
cancer to look like a Mafia Boss fine
well I'm not sitting there smoking
cigars honestly this is bad for me no
like these Vape children and
what kind of parent lets their 16 year
old Vape anyway five to 16 year old son
he's like I'll go to vape
gotta here Vape 16 year old smoke a
cigar that's the question uh like this
is now that watching some of these
videos and some of the other stuff I've
seen with him he like really Nails
certain things in like a really
beautiful like crystallized laser-like
way and then he like says these like
crazy broad things about like hitting
his kid for The Vape but yes the idea
when you see these people you see them
every now and again these people with
the Vape or sometimes it's like almost
like a box they got that big ass box and
you see them walking in a cloud of smoke
like their Skeletor like having just
done a potion or something like
something is not right with these people
and they they usually are not in great
health I have someone who you guys all
know uh perhaps a former guest of the
Reuben report who's a big Vape guy and
every time I see him I'm like dude what
are you doing with the and he never
feels that great but he's always vaping
and
so yeah uh what was the moral of that
though hit the kid
got here Vape just a push-up yeah do a
couple push-ups and uh yeah look I
mostly for the most part when it comes
to these things like anything in
moderation it's how I don't smoke
cigarettes I never have if I if I took
the amount of puffs of a cigarette that
I've ever taken in my life I don't even
think it would equal one full cigarette
like maybe 10 pups ever in my entire
life I've smoked a couple cigars over
the years I really don't like them
actually remember we went to the Patrick
bat David podcast and he's got this
awesome Cigar Lounge after and I didn't
even smoke a cigar Phoenix was smoking
and and everybody Patrick was and
Giuliani and every and I felt like I got
hit by a truck the next day you stink
but I get it and conservatives
especially absolutely love them I do
smoke weed occasionally okay cool guy
but I take like one puff of something
and I watch Seinfeld and I laugh a
little bit and then I pass out like
that's that's how I roll but I think
most things in moderation and uh the
moral of the story was hit your 16 year
old kid
uh
was that it that was it that's been Dave
Rubin reacting to Andrew Tate more next
time on these reaction programs that
we're doing thank you foreign